[Musik]
muss aufpassen instabil
das so aber es ist die haben das sieht
vielleicht hoffentlich nie mehr radler
schon drauf für mich ein stapel zum
entrückten des rinds ragout im mini form
es ist auschwitz ich hatte früher bin
ich damals als ich von der idee die
schweizer nati viel weltmeister werden
anders als im fußball stehen die chancen
dazu gut
doch wie schafft man es in kochen an die
weltspitze
davon handelt dieser film
[Musik]
wenn kochen sport ist dann ist dies die
champions league an der
weltmeisterschaft in luxemburg geht es
um tempo und disziplin
warum das beste drei-gang-menü der welt
zu kochen braucht es einen langen atem
[Musik]
fangen wir von vorne an es ist haupt 3
uhr morgens im letzten sommer das
colline r im national-team scherz zu
seinem ersten trainingseinsatz
unter der woche sind sie chefköche und
berufsschullehrer in der freizeit
trainieren sie für ihr hobby die
kochkunst
schuster sowie dass ich hier stehe
wieso tut man sich das an
mit einem klassischen faszination im
kopf
große teen spirit aber das ist nämlich
lust
[Applaus]
wettkampf modus zu gehen an diesem
sonntagmorgen im juni übt die nazi in
einem alten hotel
wochenlang haben sie getüftelt und menüs
komponiert jetzt kochen sie sie zum
ersten mal genau sechs stunden zeit
haben sie für 110 gäste noch das
positive ist an der oper laufen sind die
freu mich drauf an der wm wird eine jury
die schweizer bewerten
die kriterien sind perfekte präsentation
innovation und originalität
je besser und raffinierte alles zusammen
passt desto mehr punkte gibt es
[Musik]
da muss man auch nicht größer noch nicht
aufgegeben oder koriander damit den euro
machen
je komplexer das menü desto größer ist
die chance auf den wm titel
die zeit ist knapp berechnet das system
zu machen dass meine arbeit schätzt
thematisiert macht nicht auslöser
sondern auch entschieden und den
auslöser
damit ist effizient sind ausflüge so zu
kochen sei spitzensport sagt das team
und dieser stress fordert seine opfer
ein halbes jahr vor der wm in luxemburg
droht das team beinahe
auseinanderzubrechen
das ist auch milch bieten den vorsteuer
in ordentlichen schluss als hobby man
professionell sind fünf gleiche und die
studierenden merkels mini break und geht
jetzt in die zukunft und ich hatte jetzt
sind wir diese chance projekt machen
in der riesenchance
ich machte luxemburg mit ich weiß wie
wichtig wären durch das ist aber meine
entscheidung und ich habe entschieden
uns nächste wieder zurück und ist sie ja
psychisch halbjahr zum teil kann hat es
gemerkt und singapur das ja plötzlich
unter spannung und als familie sieht die
verstummten entscheid als ich stehe
hinter dem lieblich komplett will für
mich ist ein hobby und job kopflos mit
dem verdacht und lätta frau die
geschäfte gemacht wie im betrieb mehr
als 100 2 1% tag stellt sie der
mannschaft sieht
irgendwer hat immer funktioniert
die blau - was für express kann es ist
leider für den wettbewerbsmodus oder sie
auch sehr streng mit drei wettbewerbe
zwölf monate das heißt jede fusion
thieme kleben auch die musik bis zu 200
stunden ab der 100 prozent arbeitet
völlig einleiten die funktionen ist jene
betriebe die viel familie wo man sie
verzichte schlaf beruf gut aussehen und
so musste sofort ein möglichst
hochkarätiger ersatz gefunden werden
glücklicherweise und dank guter
vernetzung kann bald ein junges talent
neu einsteigen
ich kenne florian heller belegschaft und
mehr zeit auf dem betrieb er sich blind
vertrauen der bereits mit thomas kost
seiner schafft oder mit jeglicher
personen darunter der 40 das gar kein
problem
um ein menü für 110 personen zu kochen
braucht es ein durchdachtes
prozessmanagement keiner und griff darf
zu viel sein
experten die früher selber in der nazi
waren verfolgen das training
[Musik]
schnell zeigt sich die komplizierten
rezepte kosten zu viel zeit zeit die
beim anrichten zählt
[Musik]
vielleicht sind sie zum nächsten
die abläufe zu vereinfachen ohne beim
geschmack an intensität einzubüßen
das ist die herausforderung bis zur wm
die 110 testessen davon kaum etwas mit
es ist einfacher machen bietet der
tosende applaus schweizer kochen als
jahren schon dafür ist es aktuelle
[Applaus]
die nationalmannschaft wird gefeiert als
hätte sich schon den titel
[Applaus]
in der anschließenden manöverkritik tun
das allerdings etwas anders
laut spiegel ein anderes nackt hoffen
auf einen regen die union stehe
wenn sascha müller keine kocht uns macht
arbeitet er als chef des micro
personalrestaurants neuendorf das essen
ist bodenständig einen eintrag im gummi
hat die migros kantine natürlich nicht
sehr gut
cool hotel geschaffen und wohnideen auch
die entschädigte fried wetter hat der
familie koch und stellte den roller
gespielt da sind die stücke sie die
migros ist personalbestands hoch und für
mich soll nun die klage kann ich das
handy für mich kochen und schreibe schon
wichtig was sie nach bedarf kann man
viel machen und gut machen kaufleute rat
bekam
unter den jüngeren in der kocher zieht
sind viele kinderlos oder ohne
feste bindung nicht so sascha müller
wenn er einmal zeit hat verbringt dass
sie am liebsten mit seiner frau und den
beiden töchtern
und wenn eine geburtstag feiert dann
laden sie ein paar gäste ein und kochen
mit seinen häufigen abwesenheiten musste
die familie leben lernen
die luft über videos sache erledigen und
das kann sie und werden aus dem ruder
gelaufen ist und ich muss mit dem
angebot zusammen
das ist diesmal alles reden und wo man
schon sagen was ausgegangen ist so cool
also ist es nicht immer gut
ein paar wochen später gilt es ernst wm
in luxemburg
eine heerschar von köchen
wettkampfatmosphäre und ich dachte immer
kochen heute etwas mit sinnlichkeit zu
tun
center nicht für mehr heime oder im café
und das mit lust und sie machen das
abschmecken dass die neue rezepturen
finde richtig krass yvette bewahrt was
wirklich darum gott was zieht die stimme
darf stimmt organisationsteams team
stehen und das ist sehr verschieden
es ist kurz vor mitternacht die nazis
und zurück ins hotel in den wettkampf
küchen haben sie alles vorbereitet für
das warme programm
später folgt dann auch noch die kalte
küche nochmals zwei tage praktisch ohne
schlaf die beiden teamchefs teilen sich
das hotelzimmer diesem längste und wer
ist der neue star im voraus sprechen ob
man heute mit der mannschaft den
gesprächen und mir schon auch noch am
wenigsten
nach einer kurzen nacht fährt der
mannschaftsbus los
so musste war aber eigentlich eben noch
so gut ist als gott empfehlen also
zusätzliche mannschaft mit einem
prognose mitkochen und ich sehe die
chance und wenn alles stimmt mehr alle
gastgeber das funktioniert da hat man
auch eine chance
der titel soll
[Musik]
vor der alle warten die teams aus 30
ländern auf den einlass
die waren stark in den letzten jahren
wir erwarten dass sie ein hervorragendes
menü präsentieren werden sie schlagen
hoffen wir die schweizer sind vor allem
freunde große freunde und sehr stark
besser oder schlechter aus das sehen wir
in der küche vor dem spiel kann man das
nicht sagen dass ich den fußball
man kann als favorit antreten und im
spiel du trotzdem überraschung
[Musik]
den schweizern läuft es gut
ach ja
frau gruber und richtig sein team
appelliert das haben wir noch trainiert
daran und teuer
[Musik]
sie laden zwei des opfers gab
der team patissier ist 45 minuten im
rückstand
wird
minute brachte bastian okay du bist
draußen
liebe
msi wie kalt es ist
bitte durch was das beste für tourismus
messen sich stumm da probiert
kontrollieren
der christbaum für richtig also
weitermachen die andere endlich regen
währenddessen verfolgen kollegen aus der
ganzen welt die performance dann
abziehen
man sehe das plakat gemacht dass ich
jetzt weg ist als das was für das kurz
nachdem zu machen versuchen wo das
letzte chance ist gut okay aber immer
noch möglich so extrem noch nie bessere
und hoffen dass zusammen das wird die
spitze angreifen dann bleiben sie ihn
sehen sind
[Musik]
pascal die räume geben
und während die schweizer in der warmen
küche um den wow-effekt kämpfen suchen
andere mannschaften diesen im
sogenannten kalten programm das team
großbritannien liefert ein
soldatendenkmal als margarine
millimeterarbeit bis ins letzte detail
die tür des kalten buffet es ist die
zweite disziplin und nur wer in beiden
sparten am meisten punkte holt wird
weltmeister in diesen karten teil werden
die schweizer zwei tage später hoch
bewertet und dann ist ausgekocht die
stunde der wahrheit
jungs ist kopflos acht grammy
gern noch mal nachts vom spiel das
dessen sieht toll aus aber in service
bahnt sich eine katastrophe
eine woche lang
leider nicht gekommen
wahrscheinlich
567 schnitt 7
was mache ich den baslern
im endeffekt bereich
hallo
da sind ihre register ist möglich weil
sie gibt einfach dringt dass sie den
glauben zu verlieren
das ist so darum die richtige darüber
kommt da nichts sagen da störte es nicht
zusammengeht ist und dem auto seines
todes
für romy 2 wird es am schluss am service
scheitern
nun überlegt sich ein rekurs beim
jury-präsidentin wenn du sagst
ihr könnt das miteinander diskutieren
und ich das okay für mich
dann habe ich vertraue leistung bringen
dass da schon mit rollen aber sinnvoll
weil das wäre schade jetzt für juli ist
das jetzt egal
ja wir werden nicht mehr den teller ich
bin ganz mittel verstanden
das chaos im service habe keinen
einfluss auf die platzierung wird den
schweizern versichert aber sieht oder
sache nicht doch auch eigene schwächen
orgel in syrien heißt erfreut und und
alles top up schmeckt sich das sagt
schon wolke also zur stunde in der
u-bahn dieser relativ groß also
ich bin optimist und ich denke es
gebrannt
scharfe konkurrenten sind die amerikaner
was sagen sie zum schweizer menü
[Applaus]
der hommage an passt wunderbar zum
perfekt zubereiten hungers wir lesen und
hören sie ich habe einen tollen abend
die korrelation ist toll es macht spaß
das zu probieren mit allen handelns dann
werden sie keine depression haben wenn
die schweiz sich schlagen bringen sie
mich nicht in verlegenheit
ich sags mal so möge das beste team
gewinnen und so ist es nach vier tagen
ununterbrochenen kochens schlaflosen
nächten und mitfiebern zeit für die
verkündigung des weltmeisters
[Musik]
singapur wird sich den titel vor
schweden und den usa
so froh jetzt spezielle mit singer buch
verbindet das letzte oder dicke
freundschaft schon schön verspielt sind
auch in singapur selber c1 durch super
komme denen und sich jedes mal wieder so
das treffen mit freunden mit denen
zusammen sind
die schweizer liegen abgeschlagen auf
dem elften platz
die großen füße die schon relativ groß
das hat sich eine möglichst warmen
programm das volk wählen also meeting
platz
das nicht das kann ich nicht sagen und
groß feedback extrem schwierig also
etwas schlecht einschätzen und das was
ein abrufbar
letztlich bleibt die wertung der jury
subjektiv und so endet diese geschichte
für einmal nicht mit einem happy end für
die schweiz sondern eher wie an einer
fußball wm
ja noch
der catcher haben